It had been the same nightmare for weeks now,
but always fading into echoes as he awoke.
Not tonight, though.
Tonight, he was able to see more, to hold
on to the details of his dark, twisted dream…
and the warning it contained.
Doctor Stephen Strange had once been an accomplished
surgeon, yet fate had destined him to become
the Sorcerer Supreme of Earth after a car
accident claimed the use of his hands.
Now, Strange was a protector of his world
and countless others in the vast expanse of
the multiverse, a master of the mystic arts
wielding his skills in sorcerer and arcane
artifacts to defend against malevolent otherworldly
threats.
But even he had never seen anything like this
nightmare before.
On the night when the details of the dream
felt easier to keep a hold on, a sleeping
Stephen was shown all manner of horrors.
The world he had devoted himself to protecting
was crumbling, burning, all around was death
and suffering, the air shrill with the screams
of tortured innocent souls.
To make matters worse, within the dream, Strange
could feel the same suffering reaching out,
crossing the boundaries between realities;
it wasn’t just his world he saw dying, it
was all of them, every corner of the multiverse
falling.
It turned his stomach.
It all felt so real, not just an anxious,
unconscious fantasy of something he feared
might happen.
This was a warning, of something that would
come to pass.
The dread felt by the Sorcerer Supreme only
got worse as he witnessed a familiar figure,
injured and broken, crawling free of the rubble
of a destroyed city, the flickering light
of endless fires doing little to mask the
man’s wounds.
Instantly, Doctor Strange recognized the wounded
figure from the distinctive flared cloak he
wore to his goatee and dark hair greying at
the temples – it was him, or rather, another
version of him from a different reality within
the multiverse.
“H-help,” the other Strange said weakly.
Instantly, Stephen knelt to help his interdimensional
doppelganger up.
“What happened here?” he asked, concerned
at the vision of destruction all around.
“I couldn’t stop it,” the ‘Messenger
Strange’ replied in labored breaths; he
was wounded, fatally, barely holding on.
“Slow down, breathe,” Doctor Strange calmly
instructed his other self, still retaining
a bedside manner from his days as a surgeon.
“This vision, I take it you’re trying
to warn me of something?”
“Yes,” the dying sorcerer replied.
“I cast a spell that should reach you in
your sleep, although sending a message across
the multiverse is -” he paused to wince
in pain, feeling his already fading strength
dwindling further.
“It takes a lot more than I have left.”
“It’s alright,” Strange assured him.
“I can hear you; I’m listening.
I only wish I could do more for you.”
“It’s alright,” his variant forced a
weak smile.
“By the time this message reaches you, I’ll
already have been dead.
But you needed to be warned…”
“What happened here?”
Strange urged.
“It’s not what has happened.
It’s what’s coming.
It had to be us… of course, it did,” the
other’s breaths started slowing.
“I tried everything; I really did.
But he…
I’ve never felt power like it.”
“Just tell me who!”
Stephen shouted, aware his other self was
fading fast, desperate to hear the full warning
before the dream ended.
Already Doctor Strange’s mind was racing
with potential candidates who could have been
responsible.
He knew of a plethora of deities and destructive
creatures capable of launching attacks on
his home universe, and many who had time and
time again.
There were the likes of Nightmare and Shuma-Gorath,
and of course, his arch-nemesis Dormammu,
an entity who had long desired total control
over the plane of existence Stephen’s Earth
inhabited.
But not one of them had the power to subjugate
the entire multiverse in one fell swoop.
“Please…” Messenger Strange rasped,
leaning up to Stephen’s ear.
“Don’t make the same mistake I did.
Beware…
beware the Scarlet King.”
He collapsed, his breathing stopped as Doctor
Strange looked at the horrific sight of a
man almost identical to him dying, having
failed to prevent the chaos that was now consuming
everything.
The Sorcerer Supreme had an encyclopedic knowledge
of the mystic arts, and all kinds of occult
beings, but had never heard of the Scarlet
King.
As he woke up in a cold sweat, still feeling
the same dread he had felt in the dream, Doctor
Strange could remember the warning from his
other multiversal self.
It had to be him.
He had to stop the Scarlet King.
“The Scarlet who?”
repeated Wong, Stephen’s trusted friend
and confident, an expert in both mystic and
martial arts, as well as an accomplished scholar.
“Scarlet King, the other me was adamant
that this thing had to be stopped by another
version of me,” Doctor Strange explained.
Having woken up flustered and with growing
concern over his vision, Stephen had spent
the whole morning in the library.
The Sanctum Sanctorum had long been Strange’s
home and base of operations since he had inherited
the title of Sorcerer Supreme from the Ancient
One.
Additionally, the magical building in the
heart of New York’s Greenwich Village also
possessed a sprawling library filled with
tomes that contained what was thought to be
the sum total of all occult knowledge.
His books were filled with useful information
on spells, other planes of existence, even
detailing accounts of threats Stephen had
already faced, like Dormammu.
And yet, there was no mention of any ‘Scarlet
King.’
“I don’t understand it, my other self,
he mentioned it specifically by name, but
I can’t find a single reference to it in
any texts,” Strange sighed in frustration.
“The Book of Cagliostro, nothing, no mention
of a Scarlet King.”
“Strange,” Wong mused.
“What?”
Stephen replied.
“No, I mean it’s unusual you found nothing,”
his friend answered, trying to hide a smile
at catching Stephen in a joke.
“Perhaps the Book of Vishanti holds more
answers?
It contains all of the knowledge the great
sorcerer Agamotto collected on the mystic-”
“Nope, I already tried that,” Doctor Strange
interrupted.
“I consulted our copy of the Darkhold too
while I was at it.”
“You did what?”
Wong exclaimed, ever concerned by Stephen’s
arrogant and reckless behavior.
The Darkhold was a dangerous tome, a book
of spells used only for pure evil, written
by an elder god named Chthon.
Even though the original, true Darkhold was
out of reach, the knowledge contained within
the copy Stephen possessed was still perilous
to be exposed to.
“Oh, relax,” Strange replied in a rather
blasé manner, still absent-mindedly flicking
through the pages of another book, the Codex
Imperium.
“Damn it, I need to know what it is I’m
up against!” he yelled in frustration.
“Wong, you didn’t see what I saw in that
dream.
It was chaos, destruction unlike anything
I’ve ever felt before…”
“I understand, Stephen,” his fellow sorcerer
answered.
“And as Sorcerer Supreme, you hold a duty
to protect this reality from those that would
seek to threaten its safety.
But this is dangerous.
A being we know nothing about is rare, perhaps
consider if there is a reason why we know
nothing of this Scarlet King.
There is some knowledge that it is not meant
to be uncovered.”
“Knowledge is power, old friend,” Doctor
Strange retorted.
“And if I’m going to do my duty to protect
our reality, I need to know anything that
will give me an edge.
I’ll be in my study.”
With that, the Sorcerer Supreme strode off
to a private corner of the Sanctum.
He spent the next few restless hours using
his mastery of the occult to peer at the future.
Understanding the mystical mechanics of time
in the way he did meant Stephen was aware
that there was no singular future, but rather
millions upon millions of possible outcomes,
a web of potential courses that fate could
take, and any decision made could create a
new strand in this already tangled mess.
Still, there was no outcome where any Scarlet
King existed.
However, it was then that Doctor Strange realized
what he had been missing, a detail so small
that it had gone unnoticed but so crucial
that it changed his entire approach.
He had been thinking of the situation entirely
wrong, in an insular fashion that focused
solely on his own reality, his universe.
But the warning had come from across the multiverse,
from another Strange in another world.
What’s more was the feeling, the sense he’d
felt during the nightmare.
Although he knew nothing of his enemy, Strange
could tell that the destruction the Scarlet
King was capable of had the reach to threaten
all corners of the multiverse.
This wasn’t just a threat to his world,
but all worlds.
Strange’s search for answers about the Scarlet
King had proved fruitless thus far.
Yet, remembering this was a threat coming
from across the vastness of the infinite multiverse
oddly seemed to provide some comfort; because
there was one entity he did know of, who might
be able to help.
Hands aglow with magic, Doctor Strange performed
the correct ritual he knew would allow him
to commune with the Living Tribunal.
Sure enough, the room around him faded away,
and he was presented with the highest authority
in the multiverse.
The towering, vastly powerful entity was humanoid
in shape, save for a head floating separate
from its shoulders, with three faces; one
fully hooded, one half, and the other uncovered.
The Sorcerer Supreme had conversed on a few
occasions with the entity, enough to know
it was responsible for safeguarding the multiverse,
to prevent universes from amassing too much
power in case they threatened others, maintaining
balance, which made the fact it had done nothing
to prevent the imminent danger of the Scarlet
King all the more concerning.
“Speak, Strange,” the Tribunal’s booming
voice commanded, speaking from its front,
unhooded face.
“Living Tribunal.
I have come seeking answers,” Doctor Strange
replied.
“There is a being, an entity that poses
a threat to my world and all others in the
multiverse.”
“I am not aware of such a threat,” the
multiversal arbiter replied.
“Please!”
Strange urged.
“It’s out there, and I need to be the
one to stop it.
There’s no information on it in my universe,
so I ask you, please tell me where I can find
someone…
anyone who knows about the Scarlet King…”
There was silence for a moment as the different
faces of the Living Tribunal conferred.
All three had to agree on whether or not it
could interfere.
“The answers you seek lie beyond your universe,”
the Tribunal finally answered.
“We are… in agreement.
I will send you there.
But exercise caution, Stephen Strange…”
In a flash, Doctor Strange had appeared somewhere
new.
The room was dark, filthy, nothing short of
bleak.
But still, it was a far cry from the devastation
he had seen in his vision.
The walls were covered in scribbled writing,
that had seemingly been scrawled over every
surface by someone in a state of madness.
There was one that caught Doctor Strange’s
attention: a figure, adorned in red armor,
large antler-like horns protruding from his
head.
It didn’t take someone with as much knowledge
of the Sorcerer Supreme to know that this
was a drawing of the illusive Scarlet King
himself.
“Who’s there?”
A voice rasped.
Stephen turned to see an old man, withered
and alone, laying on a grimy hospital bed
in a corner of the room.
“Sorry, I didn’t see you,” he said calmly,
cautiously approaching, only lowering his
guard when he heard the elderly man give a
hoarse throat.
“You’re very sick,” Strange remarked.
“Dying, I should think,” the man replied.
“Are you Foundation?”
“Foundation?”
the sorcerer echoed in confusion.
“Yes, yes, don’t be surprised, I know
all about them,” the anonymous man said
weakly.
“I haven’t forgotten when I used to work
there.
Or how they feel about what I know… they’d
stop at nothing to silence me.
God knows they’ve tried over the years.”
“Listen, I was sent here because I need
answers,” Doctor Strange interrupted, aware
of the impending threat he felt the need to
avert.
“So, Mister-”
“Doctor!”
the old man corrected.
“Doctor Robert Montauk.”
“Doctor Montauk,” Stephen echoed.
“What can you tell me about the Scarlet
King?”
Montauk started chuckling, a dry, wheezing
sound, almost like he was taunting the sorcerer.
His laughter lasted far longer than that of
a sane man; paired with the drawings and markings
on the walls, Stephen was certain something
inside Robert Montauk was broken.
“Oh, I could tell you so much about the
Scarlet King, I was one of his Children once…
so long ago now,” he sighed, a loud, hacking
cough brought on by his laugher, forcing its
way out of Montauk’s throat.
“But that’s his strength, you see.
Being known, being understood.”
“Look, this being is threatening my world.
I need to know how I’m supposed to stop
him?”
Strange asked.
“Stop him?”
Doctor Montauk chuckled at him.
“What makes you think you can?”
“I was told I have to,” the Sorcerer Supreme
admitted.
“It has to be me.
And if you won’t tell me what I need to
know, then I’m very sorry.
Normally I’d never do this, but in the grand
calculus of the multiverse, there is nothing
I won’t sacrifice to protect it.”
With a wave of his hands, Doctor Strange conjured
his third eye, which snapped open in the centre
of his forehead.
It functioned as an organic manifestation
of his amulet, the powerful mystical artifact
known as the Eye of Agamotto.
And through it, Stephen peered into Doctor
Montauk’s fractured mind, seeking out the
information he was withholding about the Scarlet
King.
“No, no, you can’t!”
Montauk shouted, his frail, withered hands
gripping his temples as he felt the sorcerer
invading his memories.
“I’m sorry,” Strange repeated.
“But knowledge is power, and I need to know
how to stop the Scarlet King.”
“You think knowledge is power?”
the old man rasped.
“It’s more than that to him.
It’s a weapon… his weapon.
The more we know him…”
It was too late.
Doctor Strange had found what he was looking
for.
Years earlier, Doctor Robert Montauk had been
working at the SCP Foundation and had uncovered
the true nature of SCP-001, Tufto’s Proposal,
otherwise known as the Scarlet King.
The King was an elder god, a force of pure
chaos and the manifestation of a hatred for
modernity.
But it was far worse than that…
A huge, crimson crack split through the concrete
wall, a doorway to the Scarlet King’s domain.
Pulling himself out of Robert Montauk’s
mind the second he realized his mistake, Doctor
Strange was still reeling as the portal opened.
How could he have been so stupid?
His nightmare hadn’t been a warning to prevent
what was coming, it was either a warning to
stay away… or a trap.
Snapping back to awareness, Stephen found
he was no longer in the filthy room where
the dying Doctor Montauk lay.
Instead, he was in a vast multiversal void,
a space between universes.
And there, among the huge expanse of nothingness,
stood the Scarlet King.
He towered above Doctor Strange, his physical
form adorned in armor the shade of blood.
Atop his head was a crown-like ornament, the
large antlers jutting out above.
His hands were gnarled claws, clenched into
massive fists, and his many eyes were looking
at Stephen.
Having seen inside Montauk’s mind, Doctor
Strange had realized all too late that the
Scarlet King was more than just an ancient
evil being.
He was a living idea, given form by every
attempt to study, quantify and define exactly
what the King was.
He was the very notion of nihilism, shaped
by a hatred of the modern world and a desire
to return to a more violent age, but if nobody
talked about him, he would gain no further
power.
The Scarlet King had only grown in strength
the more the SCP Foundation had tried to learn
about him.
And now, the Sorcerer Supreme himself had
done the same.
The King had achieved even greater power thanks
to Strange falling into his trap, enough to
open up a gateway and bring him here.
“You already know, don’t you, sorcerer?”
the Scarlet King snarled, his voice sounding
like billions upon billions of insects chittering.
“Through Montauk, you know.”
Stephen looked in horror at the interdimensional
abomination.
Even just by observing him, being able to
perceive his physical form, he was unintentionally
empowering the entity.
But living idea or not, Strange had seen the
destruction that the Scarlet King could unfurl
on the multiverse.
“By the Hoary Hosts of Hoggoth,” Doctor
Strange declared, summoning up a spell that
he hoped would reverse whatever power the
King possessed.
“You will not harm my world, nor any others!”
Unleashing his magic in a blast of light,
the beam struck the Scarlet King.
The elder god was harmed, but not undone;
the forces of the mystic arts being almost
as ancient as the Scarlet King was, and thus,
he could still be hurt.
The Scarlet King raised a mighty fist, bringing
it slamming down towards Stephen.
He was barely able to cast the Shield of Seraphim,
creating a protective circle of mystical energy
that formed a barrier between Strange and
the oncoming attack.
As the descending, gigantic fist of the Scarlet
King was deflected, he instantly brought his
other down in a vicious attack.
The sheer force of it broke Stephen’s concentration,
causing the Shield to dissipate, barely withstanding
enough of the King’s physical strength to
prevent the Sorcerer from being knocked down.
It was like one magically powered ant fighting
against a being impossibly bigger, that could
stomp Strange out of existence in seconds.
But even falling to the imperceptible ground
of the void, Doctor Strange didn’t let up,
refusing to relent and let the Scarlet King
unleash his wrath on the multiverse.
His Cloak of Levitation lifted him back to
his feet, and with a wave of both hands, Stephen
burst into multiple astral-projected copies
of himself: the Images of Ikonn.
The multiple Doctor Stranges floated independently
through the air, surrounding the Scarlet King.
Then, as every Stephen gave an outward flick
of his wrist, the Crimson Bands of Cyttorak
flew from their hands.
The bright red belts of energy, virtually
indestructible, bound the powerful, chaotic
King, lashing around his physical form.
But still, Doctor Strange being able to see
and perceive the Scarlet King was granting
his adversary power.
He pulled with all his physical strength,
the Crimson Bands starting to wane, slackening
despite Strange’s efforts to keep all his
duplicates holding on.
Gripping the bands in his huge, gnarled hands,
the Scarlet King swung the multiple Stranges
around, forcing them all back into the same,
singular body as they collided.
Still holding the one remaining Crimson Band
of Cyttorak, the Scarlet King started to drag
Stephen towards him.
The King didn’t want him dead, Strange knew
it.
He’d be tortured, made and unmade even until
the entity forced him to use his third eye
again, like he had done to Doctor Montauk.
If Doctor Strange could fully comprehend the
Scarlet King’s nature, origin, and ideology,
then the King would be able to achieve his
full strength.
That was the trap the Sorcerer Supreme had
been lured into.
His own arrogance, his need to be the one
who saved the multiverse, the man holding
the scalpel, was a weakness the Scarlet King
was prepared to exploit in order to achieve
the power he needed to overthrow the multiverse.
There was only one thing left that Doctor
Strange could do, one last ditch effort.
It was a long shot, but he hoped it would
be enough.
Releasing his remaining band, Stephen began
casting a spell to send a message to another
of his selves somewhere else in the multiverse.
He could hear the Scarlet King looming behind
him, ready to strike.
Maybe the King would kill him, but Strange
wouldn’t let that stop him casting the spell.
His warning would reach his other self even
after death, in the form of a dream.
A warning not to make the same mistake as
this Strange had; to not go searching for
the Scarlet King.
Now go and check out “DEADPOOL VS SCP-682”
and “SCP-001 - The Scarlet King” for more
wild battles and eldritch monsters!